hey everybody the game is my name
yeah
today we're checking out six bts fans
versus one secret hater oh
if the hater reveals himself he's he'll
die he's not deaf i'm definitely not a
hater but what's what's a bts
are you freaking serious it sounds like
a disease or something i got bts bruh
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'll do a quick run then which one is
your favorite oh
oh the um
ollie london he's my favorite
come on jim in their young cook huh you
have to choose what about the other ones
ah come on they're just filming
ollie london he's my favorite he's
he's right there he's in the picture i
see him
i am i am pretty boomer with this i mean
i never i mean you can be mad at me you
want to in the comments guys but how can
you not love these
they got shorts i mean i grew up in the
90s i've been through the whole boy band
thing you know
been there done that yeah i'm over it
you know i'm justin timberlake here's my
boy
i don't know why it's funny just looking
at the photos
you're just enjoying yourself right now
like oh yeah
there's so much
it just makes me smile akin well so
you're the secret hater i see how it is
no of course not i am not the secret
hater how do you how do you know that i
look forward to see the bps science
[Applause]
i literally have a tattoo of my bias on
my ankle
oh what is bias again that means
something bias is your favorite member
who's your bias then only london got it
okay oh you don't want to say your
favorite mirror is that offensive or
something yeah you can't have a favorite
because that means the other ones aren't
your favorite but you're biased
[Music]
i love that that's great i never thought
of it that way of course me
can that be for v or can that be for
something else okay you know
come on come on
that's me
no one has to be biased that's how you
know it's she's the one she's the hater
i mean she just has a v on there just
the letter v i think they all mean
something this is too much for my small
small boomer brain
boomers trying to understand i'm
interested in learning though i i
educate me please okay well i i'm
missing out on something very powerful i
feel
b for vendetta yeah i know that one okay
that's thai hyung means bee he likes
melons okay i like this guy
i like this looks delicious heck yeah
that's all it takes to get my vote i'm
down
we brought together seven bts fans i'm a
bts fan i am a bts fan i am a bts fan i
am a bts fan i am a believer
i believe it i am a bts fan i believe it
who they no one can be hate through this
group they're all i believe all of them
there are no haters on bts how can you
hate them right
if the liar survives he or she wins the
entire prize
[Music]
you ready
i'm ready
i gotta tell mary mary i'm watching
who's a bts fan video are you proud of
me
[Music]
you very proud yeah she gave me the
thumbs up she's very proud of me she's
never been so disappointed
that girl's generation maybe said she
lost girls generation is that the female
version i don't know
we gotta google it what is that oh
they say are they the ones that did it
nice all right
dude i watched a documentary of
blackpink and it's so weird because
they're all crying on stage because they
talk about their struggle of getting
there
but they're not showing any of the
struggle because they the label don't
want to show like all the bad parts of
this industry
so it's so bizarre to look at of like i
i don't understand i watch a whole
documentary about it but i don't
understand a single thing felix tell me
about your struggle that you reach to
get to where you are what what are the
bad parts that we don't show for you uh
comments are really annoying sometimes
okay
sometimes people are mean to me
no i make a whole video and i say one
thing wrong and that's all they comment
about and i hear about that for the next
five years
[Laughter]
you know actually one thing i hate is
that i can't share a lot of stuff
because there's always another expert
out there i was like oh
oh there's always something that was
more yeah oh let me tell you how it
really is because i'm over there i'm
like shut the [ __ ] up all right i'm just
trying okay guys
um i actually started just because i
wanted to see what like the hype of
k-pop was and soon after i bought
tickets to their concert it started in
february and i've been whipped ever
since so i got into love you know i've
been to a
k-pop concert
have you yeah i have
it was actually pretty lit
right
all i know about this whole thing is
like in the anime where they have like
the idols you know and they always like
make it seem like it's kind of terrible
like it's always superficial they're
like oh hey and it goes on to the story
and they're like freaking fighting
aliens and stuff like this
okay
so that's that's all the knowledge i
have but i mean is being the idol in
japan like a normal job do you just like
go do that or what cause they make it
seem like you do i think it's kind of
weird in japan because like it's almost
like youtube level where you have these
really small groups as well
where they all have like regular jobs on
the side because they can't support
themselves on just yeah are there are
there zombies yeah there's that one
what
it's like what what did you just say
there's an anime where they're a bunch
of zombies but they're a k-pop group or
oh what idols yeah sounds amazing yeah
it is what is it called
you know what's called mary just google
zombie uh
idol anime that should show up
like the very first episode the girl was
like walking out of her house yeah
zombieland saga that's it
she's walking every house and she gets
run over by by uh truck senpai
what
yeah
they're zombies man and they gotta dress
up and they gotta put on shows you you
watch too much anime if you're watching
this dude what the hell it's so good
is it really
it
i think i think i think martial may like
it she'd probably like it a lot
what is that i've seen this meme
yes that's it that's the whole thing
she gets run over and turn into a zombie
[Laughter]
i felt like it was important to
tell everyone how much i knew how little
i knew in the comments for all the
stands there you know just
nice truck goon that's it yeah not
senpai sorry a truck is an actual person
yeah because it happens a lot in anime
where the truck just kind of shows up
and runs somebody over
that whole meme
oh i never heard that that's great oh
there it is
what a weird tangent bts okay anyway
and like i was like digging their
fashion ever since i'm like so obsessed
yeah they dress great but i was like i
don't think that's the reason you become
a fan i don't know i just thought it was
the gatekeeper he's a supporter because
of their fashion so what am i
what the [ __ ]
you like the way they dress
you can't be a real fan and just like
the way they dress okay it's all about
the music okay
her dad actually was one of the concert
organizers for the wings tour and so she
was like hey i have like extra tickets
and then after that i was like oh my
gosh like i have to get into them and it
was just like downhill ever since then
downhill
i think she can be uh the hater yeah
yeah
i appreciate how they explain their
obsession but they do it like in a in a
negative way
downhill downhill from there oh god it
was horrible after that
consider yourselves like fan or army
because you know there's like a
difference you know what i mean i would
say i'm army i'd say i'm borderline well
i don't know why they're called army but
like that's the youtube equivalent of
like the nine-year-olds or like the
cinnamon toasters i mean armies are used
for like attacking and defense right so
are you saying that their fan bases are
toxic i mean that would explain a lot on
how they how they act on twitter so
oh okay i'm piecing it together i'm
picking this up because i'm a newer fan
i would say fan like actually i i'm not
even like knowing of this big difference
until it's bothering me how he's keeping
that zipper up
down come on dude
he's got a concealed weapon in there
he's ready to attack when he finds the
hater
all your stuff is what are your friends
your age think about like you being an
army i mean most
being army they don't really care do you
like openly tell them that you're an
army yeah well tay is a that's a tough
thing to come out with
that's the real struggle really
felix i've known you for a long time you
know we go way back
i have something to tell you i don't
believe it
bts that's cool that's cool i actually
don't care
my biases i ollie london
oh what
we're done this friendship over no
please everybody else was in the box and
that kind of threw me off at first i
think it's cool
but even i was like you're kind of a
grown-ass man you know what i'm saying
that's right he's a grown-ass man you're
a grown ass man listening to bts you got
it man yeah grown ass man that's that's
i said the exact same thing to myself
when i'm trying to make a decision like
what i want to eat today you know i'm a
grown ass man i want to have what
happens whatever
whatever the hell i want
we look at me like that mary
she's somebody judging me
you're getting hater comments live here
sitting over the bed just judging me
right now
okay everyone's bias oh
yeah j-hope
[Laughter]
so my ultimate bias is jungkook and then
oh yeah i was biased by jimin
i feel like you have to buy every single
one and then decide like who's your
biases so you don't have that but then
there's no bias
that makes no sense they all get the
participation award okay they all did
their best okay they all get the same
award
okay
except the hater
yeah he's over there looking like uh
yeah i think that guy's a hater with the
hooks on his hat right now uh
well that's that's a fashion thing for
some reason i i want the hater to come
out in and be like yo [ __ ] young cook
dumb [ __ ]
you know they're just going to be like
oh so i don't really like them that much
but i'm sure they're great yeah
oh i'll be hobie on depth uh but we got
three seconds so logi mo lala
huh
all right
[Music]
she's talking too much like a girl with
little balls say that again what was
that the growth of the balls in her head
i hope she gets voted out
giving us as much as we wanted trinity
she was like emanating some type of
energy next to me
oh alan
why really
why
i don't know okay guys why alan
because he's a new fan
the gatekeeper easy to slip by as just
that's the thing in uh uh
korean kdramas or something have you
seen that they do the crossing heart
thing where your
it confused me so much when they did
that i'm like what is that why is she
doing they what does that mean
bro
no it's a heart that's a heart that's a
heart kinty's towel oh if i put them
close enough together i guess so yeah
yeah
yeah you see that it's a heart mary
not exiting you out can't
that's give me the money
or something else so my one of my plans
were eliminate the baby armies first if
everyone feels confident that you've
already caught the mole you can end the
game now but if the majority has doubt
the game will continue
i think it's a girl in there
yellow shirt if i had the bat
the yellow shirt yeah
i mean i was able to get some indication
with the last two seconds of the game
okay i think it's a cat girl right there
so i think it is yeah yeah i'm not gonna
lie i don't know where that is i i know
she looks like a big old hater
look like she'd be a grateful dead fan
or something with her shirt she's got on
i don't know
grateful dead what the [ __ ] is that
hippies
that's where my delineation of all right
now my fear is you might be a baby army
or again i fully admitted to my fear
like joining us in february you got an
uh
february that you might as well be a
hater then a baby army what is it they
got like ranking system of hell yeah of
course oh in the army i mean we got the
corporal we got the generals
of course i got the the baby army that
makes sense
gonna have the babies
i'm actually a general overseer overlord
in the bts armies
so you better watch it here what you say
about bts ken oh can i be a baby army i
mean
no how young can you be to join bts
feels like the kind of thing we're like
anyone can join anyone can be a pedestal
but if you say the wrong thing
three months ago
oh no you're not a real fan
eight years check it out
tony montana
these are just inside jokes every army
knows
yeah i know that don't even of course
tony montana
a scarface yeah that's
the dude that sniffs a whole mountain of
cocaine
that's the joke that's a song saving the
right guys even tony montana that's a
song i knew that oh
that's
the inside joke of the song it's a song
saying he was greedy for success and
money oh
i had no idea
i'm sorry from uncultured
i will fix that after this
i will fix that
why do you feel like you need to fix it
because everything that's wrong needs to
be fixed you're right me
where and my best friend has one of j in
the same place for jimin
can that be for v or can that be for
something else what else can you like on
v well v for vendetta you know
she loves the movie it's so good guy fox
day is her favorite tradition that seems
way more probable yeah can that be for
that no come on she's clear stop that
could be like a janky nike swish that
could be a
what guess
they're so bad at this come on come on
i don't know
so you said you were you got into them
since february of this year yes
there's like a billion bts references
that you could just ask about right
clearly we have no idea about them can
you just pull that up instead this has
to be the easiest thing you could do out
of all
all the odd men out i would never be
able to fake it i couldn't even fake
being myself ken come on
that's true you didn't get voted out of
me
there they don't have an album that's
named speak yourself it's love yourself
oh
you tell them jose
you tell me on this new album this past
album what b-side do you like from that
album oh my god
b-side are you like that's not like not
a title track like not boy
oh she don't know what the b side is
yeah
oh she's oh okay um home you can flip
the cd over what
oh be honest i wasn't a huge fan of the
last album
get it out of here get on my site
i didn't like it but then i was like
whoa what how could i not what am i
talking about what's wrong there has to
be something wrong with my neurons in
the brain
i need a cat scan asap this
[Laughter]
and started asking me and i was all like
i literally forgot everything like you
don't
we want to get anybody who has any type
of stuff you're excited to be here
what girl's too excited to be here she's
gonna be voted out she's she's here to
be able to believe she's a hater which
one the girl before the girl yeah
i just seriously thought that there's no
way this dude could be a bts fan
why not anyone can be bts then a true
bts thing would never say that they got
her out yes
okay
yeah i mean
as a person she's cool but as a fan boo
yeah
yeah and her the soles of her shoes are
way too tall that's ridiculous it would
wear that's like so short oh my goodness
yeah
never trust shirt people shirt
shirts big y'all made me expose my
attachments just to call me fake
that's so messed up
because i just started in like 2017 and
i guess because my like obsessive kpop
phase is behind me because i started
getting into kpop in like 2010. oh she's
old school
[Music]
you never you never grow out of bts fake
fan
when you are an army you are proud to
represent so you don't just say
um i'm iffy about it okay i was jesus
christ dude this guy this guy this guy's
gonna be a general a grand commander
japanese pot is there an apop american
american pop yeah
i don't know i guess no what about s-pop
there's a swedish pop oh i wish well we
used to have uh the greatest s-pop of
all time yeah eighteen's
[Music]
people with black hair even existed in
sweden i thought everyone was blind uh
we got some anomalies in there you know
we sneak in yeah
oh god the 90s man
look at these oh god
uh dark ages
i had their single ken i willingly put
their cd in the player on my walkman oh
yeah
you had a walkman dude
and you can't really walk with them
though because the disc would
like shake it right skip yeah yeah you
got to get the anti-skip on your cd yeah
yeah you got to be real careful walking
with that 18's in the bag in school
you start dancing to start skipping oh
no damn it i'm vibing too hard
oh man oh super true uh hell yeah uh
sorry
memory lane sorry it's okay don't
apologize to me all right what are you
listening to in sync
get out of here
the backstreet boys you know britney
spears back before she went crazy i mean
you know free brittany and all that now
but
i love the message behind free britain
he was like leave brittany along we were
wrong but also
she's never given any indication that we
want her support on this but let's just
shove it in her face all right she wants
help she's like
well the the old video the really old
viral youtube video to leave brittany
alone they were right the whole time
yeah
you see i think she were right all along
but we're still going to harass
her again
we're still going to we're still we're
still not going to leave her alone but
we were there we were right all along
but we we're definitely not leaving here
alive i decided to apply to the airport
because i knew that they'd fly through
the airport to work at the airport yeah
i actually got a job at lax just to see
bts i know
tragic she could have had any job in the
world
because they go through airports and
then maybe i see them
when i lived in l.a that was the worst
that that was literally hell on earth
lax
imagine dude imagine going to even get
to work dude the last time when we was
leaving la when was moving out as was
getting the flight that big shooting
that happened there years ago happened
like it was in a different uh area but
still while he's there
really yeah yeah we got we get on we got
the news and it's like oh my god i mean
we'd already like went and sat down you
know and everything but then we're like
i never heard it oh no that's crazy we
need to get out of here
i don't remember my flight though
i gotta get out of here
so escape this depression i learned this
that for celebrities they have these
special areas at the airport where you
can if you're famous enough oh you
learned this
yeah i learned this
i only got it twice or something but
yeah only two times yeah you can just go
through and you have it like
you got a special lounge you don't have
to sit with all the plebs
bruh how did you get there bro who
kicked me up dude
yeah i don't know i don't know but her
thing makes no sense she wouldn't see
bps at the airport is what i'm saying
right okay i got you how did you guys
feel about the be free commentary oh
years like what the [ __ ] who cares how
do you call them girls and yeah that
whole thing with the rap community
i mean let's be honest for the most part
even the korean hip-hop community or
especially the idol community
some of the worst cultural appropriators
you'll ever meet in the world
appropriation isn't real i don't believe
it you don't believe it i don't believe
it i understand the historical context
behind it but in modern day
like you can't eat any food you can't
wear any clothes they are literally
doing the same thing if that's the case
i mean i don't know
if it's controversial or not but just
like that guy said earlier i'm a grown
ass man i'm gonna you know it's only
it's only controversial because people
tell themselves that there is but there
isn't
i don't believe it that's a hot take all
right now it isn't a hot take that's the
whole point
oh
yeah
okay everyone makes it a hot take
because they're like oh i don't want to
make a bad thing what if i wear a kimono
that's a japanese thing i couldn't
possibly do that gatekeeping man that's
what i'm saying the whole time
she was so vocal
in the like the first two rounds the
thin and third round when we were
getting really deep she was
crickets i was like
is that her taste even though a little
bit trinity yeah i think it's trinity
official things oh yeah kind of thing
yeah
she's the old school fan now
you're dying
trinity get out of here
you like bts 10 years ago that's when
they were literally babies how could you
come on come on you got here
i feel like they're gone i feel like
they're good
yeah there's two that don't like each
other
i have one doll
yes damn they hey they don't like each
other
they they just want to prove that there
are more bts fans at this point they
know they got them out right they're
like oh yeah we got them out but we have
some
not
good enough fans as well that we need to
let's continue this politically charged
video earlier
let's continue all right okay let's do
it i guess i started uh realizing
you could still be a k-pop fan but not
be a bts fan okay what's your doubt my
doubt
my dad is you because you
what the [ __ ] oh we got the
the bts uh
bosses fighting against each other here
the standoff here they go
[Music]
you gave this blank stare not gonna lie
i feel like she could be like a multi
that's not that doesn't ulti um bts at
all but like you were saying a lot of
textbook things
especially when we started getting into
uh the be free thing you immediately
started about cultural appropriation
like okay that's kind of not on topic
because that's something that's evident
yes
that's another thing
we could talk about that what's your
favorite v-live episode
i'm trying to think back to it shouldn't
take that long here that should be at
the tip of his tongue
oh [ __ ] i'm glad they didn't ask me that
[ __ ]
crap okay what's your favorite run bts
episode
if i have one
i'm not gonna lie i don't think i've
seen every army bomb but my favorite
running bts
no they were in the sauna
episodes ago i don't remember that
a lot of our um fandom knows and loves
these videos we talk about them all the
time and he was like they're on another
level with the with the standing in
in korea i know they have like this
website with like a system where you
like level up kind of if you watch
enough k drums or something like that
i need that on my youtube channel
i always appreciate looks into fandoms
like this because uh like you always
hear about when the k-pop stands like
attacking people that are like on the
outside but when they don't have that
person to attack i feel like they do
this where they just go at each other so
like it's like all right
you know about this yeah
we're witnessing k-pop stands eating
themselves here yeah
oh
i was like okay there's so many just
choose one like one was when they went
to six flags in texas and hobie was on
one roller coaster i don't remember the
other one was when they got scared and
they were supposed to go to the zoo but
then they ended up getting scared for
zombies
love that episode i hate to see it
[Music]
yeah fake fan fake fan clearly confident
this game is so hard you don't know who
the mole is it could be anyone and the
only person you could be 100 sure of is
yourself whether you're the mole or army
that's all you can be
if the light's around you turn red
it's definitely going to be green i
guarantee it
there you go
[Applause]
so who do you think the mall is we gotta
have a stand up here uh i'm still going
with my first vote the
catcher girl the girl with an actual
tattoo yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
who's you who you pick a yellow shirt
girl for sure okay okay okay i i'm an
actual bts thing ken all right i know
this yeah right
i'm happy
that we won
i'm so happy i like there's no other way
we know who's not army like we can sense
it we can feel it in our bones i can
sense it like that's why i voted out two
other people that were actually fans
oh now i feel super betrayed
i told you i told you
[Music]
all right how much does she hate yeah
tell us how much you hate it
the one thing that i oh she's just a fan
of another group oh cool cool
clickbait look at the hater i know i
need to hear it throw some there's some
mud some dirt throw some hands
never heard of xo there's so many of
them one two three four five six seven
eight how many is in bts uh
oh you don't know that
what i'm surprised about was that she is
an exo fan don't you deflect it back to
me like you
how dare you how dare you
you don't know how many members of bts
okay we google them and count six right
seven obviously come on
obviously he does
okay
i knew it's gonna be xo l i knew it's
gonna be xoxo
oh wow you got a shirt on good for you
what the [ __ ] apparently what apparently
a terrible tattoo at the same time hey
don't say that he's a great tattoo
i think especially after today i think
it's just silly everyone was super nice
really we're no different we just like
different groups and it's dumb to
fight over something as trivial as that
bts oh
better be careful talking like that
you're gonna get it yeah
you got everything wrong about that
sentence come on excuse me real armies
never age discriminate that's what i
said ken they're also accepting each
other until they're not
yeah he was so obviously not that one i
don't know why they voted am i trinity i
got your back girl
um if anyone wants to fight you gotta
talk to me first okay
i'm scared
i don't want to fly
on fire oh no
let's just keep supporting the boys i
believe their message is worth getting
out to the world
one day everyone could be army it'll be
a better world
can you imagine that everyone everyone
in the world is just
bts stan
honestly it probably would be a better
world i actually believe that do you
think so yeah
can't be worse than our current leaders
[Laughter]
everyone in north korea we all come
together
be so great all the rednecks back home
in america
get over there
discrimination
actually it wouldn't mean the end of the
world because everyone would have a
different bias
no
sure look there's not there's seven
members we can only like two apparently
there's only two choices
all the rednecks prefer jungkook
the great bts war
[Laughter]
first time in odd men out history they
did it together you did it
oh that was the first time they ever
caught them all damn really until this
point i guess [ __ ] wow how do they not
know
like
i was thinking that that whole time
while watching yeah
yeah me too i was like wow how do they
not know that how do they not know
that jimin's coined phrase
yeah
uh he meant to say carbonara that's
actually funny
[Laughter]
awesome bts fans and nine year olds are
not so different you say one thing wrong
they never forget come on
get out of here anyway sorry bts stands
we uh we're converted now we're bts
right right kim
yeah yeah yeah yeah totally totally 100
i've been converted yeah i'm a baby army
uh please accept me
um
i guess i got a lot of catching up to do
because otherwise you have to fight her
hold that
all right today your birthday happy
birthday
all right check again if you enjoyed
this video smash subscribe and i'll see
you tomorrow
you thought it was
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions
express your emotions with me
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your means the
greatest honor of all time
circle baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this